[Music]
after a season of frustration right
there Regina and her team have a killer
whale in sight miss coming towards the
edge now they just needed to be in range
often the whales pop up out of nowhere
but you got half a second to take your
aim because the things moving and you
need to shoot it while it's moving and
it's only above the water for a short
period it's coming this way rolling
right there
[Music]
Hey
awesome perfect it's alright good
there's a little piece of blubber and
skin they'll take a little piece of skin
smaller than the end of my fingernail
but that's enough for us to do genetics
and also stable isotope analysis stable
isotopes allow us to position where the
animal is eating in the food chain and
so it helps us to reconstruct what the
diet of the whale is once we match those
with the photo IDs we start to
understand family structure and
population size information from a
single whale helps the team learn about
the individual but multiple samples help
them understand a section of the
population and that's the goal they've
been working toward all season Regina
Regina there's the other one
successes if you get any samples what we
need as many kilowatts as we can big
pile out over here here he is
daddy you reacted there's a group right
out over there there's more out there I
hate to say it but I told you that would
be whales
sound other one coming
[Music]
got her I didn't even see it
good shot I'm very pleased with those
apples because so this is a lot of work
getting as opposed to some days he got
50 Wells mailing around and they just
all over the place and Jonah would shoot
first we had run up and down the ice
edge and there was one or two animals at
a time where - chaser oh we finally saw
some whales we had to move fast to get
to him here we go here we go he's closer
he's right here
he's right there nice shot Regina just
Thumb got a biopsy from that second big
male in that group nice like yeah
we got six biopsies I think we did
really good on the photo IDs that first
group it was the same group over and
over again so we probably got that whole
family group Regina Islander place where
the whales are Regina ended up getting
biopsies we've got good data as we work
it up we're gonna be able to do a lot
with it good day all right we did good
[Music]